YING FEI: Hi, everyone.
I'm Ying, product manager
working on AI and industry
solutions at Google Cloud.
In this session, I will
be sharing with you
how our visual
inspection AI products
support manufacturing customers
to transform their business.
Sudhi from Accenture will also
be joining me in this session.
Would you want to
introduce yourself Sudhi?
SUDHINDRA KRISHNAMURTHY: Thank
you Ying for your partnership
support and for giving
us an opportunity
to present at Google Next.
Hello everyone.
I'm Sudhindra from Accenture,
responsible for building
industry solutions on Google
Cloud and part of Accenture
Google business group.
YING FEI: Cool.
So besides the two of us,
Tigran and Alex at Siemens
also created a video
to share their adoption
story for our visual
inspection product.
In the end of this session,
we will get a chance
to take a look at the video.
So let's get started.
In the current market,
demand volatility
puts lots of pressure
on manufacturers.
The decreased demand for the
new product, the disruption
of the retail channels, and
the interruption of the supply
chain operation make
it really challenging
for the manufacturers to
maintain business continuity.
The manufacturers are motivated
to decrease cost and improve
work efficiency by automating
many of their work processes.
Visual inspection technologies
are there to help,
but the adoption of
these new technologies
can be difficult and costly.
The traditional
inspection devices
cost millions of
dollars per device.
The deployment and the adoption
of these new technologies
require the support of the IT
infrastructures and the domain
experts.
The limited amount
of sample data
make it really challenging to
analyze the product quality
and to train machine
learning models
for automating the visual
quality control process.
To solve all these
challenges, Google
has partnered with several
of the industry leaders
to build a best-in-class
visual inspection technology
to help the manufacturing
customers really transform
their business.
We have a rich computer
vision product offering.
It includes the pre-trained
APIs, the AutoML product,
and several of the
new products that we
are building to support the
industry-specific use cases.
All of these products will be
available on GCP very soon.
End of last year, Forrester
has ranked Google Cloud
as the leader for the
computer vision product,
both because its current product
offering and its future product
strategy.
Our visual inspection
product could
be used to support a
variety of the use cases.
For example, cosmetic inspection
for the electronic product
and assembly inspection to
look for missing or damaged
component on the assembled
product, weld inspection
for the automotive
manufacturing,
wafer layer inspection
for semiconductors,
and packaging
material inspection
for consumer packaged goods.
One of our Lighthouse
customers, Foxconn FIH,
they built a visual
inspection solution
using our visual inspection
product for the six components
they want to inspect on the
assembled PCB assembly board.
We helped them achieve lower
than 1% of the defect escape
rate and false alarm rate.
By deploying this solution,
they achieved significant cost
saving on their
production lines.
Another of our Lighthouse
customer is GlobalFoundries.
They used our product for
inspecting the wafer layers.
This helped them improve the
inspection rate to over 95%.
Within few months of starting
to implement this solution,
they successfully migrated
over 40% of the manual workload
to this automated solution.
This helped them scale
the automated solution
much faster than they expect.
In the next session, I will
hand it over to Sudhi for him
to share about how
Accenture has been
partnering with Google for
building visual inspection
solutions.
SUDHINDRA KRISHNAMURTHY:
Thank you Ying.
I would like to start giving
an overview of our partnership
with Google.
The Accenture Google
Business Group
has formed about five
years ago, and it
is designed to bring the best
of Google human-centric design
technology and innovation with
Accenture's capability industry
experience and intelligence.
Accenture's AI visual
inspection offering
enables multiple industry
use cases for an enterprise
through a
platform-based approach.
What this means
for our clients is
an AI-based visual
inspection platform
running on Google Cloud
offering automated and improved
inspection solutions,
[INAUDIBLE] of quality
control, safety surveillance,
asset tracking, and diagnosis,
governing both in production
and non-production environments
for multiple industries.
Our key business value focuses
on reducing inspection time,
inspection cost, and
the false positive cases
and false negative cases.
Our platform is architecture
to offer flexibility
to run AI services, both
on the Cloud and Edge,
addressing practically
requirements in the client
environment.
As part of our hybrid
solution offering,
Accenture can help with the
advanced imaging solutions,
recommending the best
camera and installation
for the solutions required.
We provide automation services
for inspection use cases
supporting with the integration,
such as with robotics
and drone-based solutions.
In addition to Cloud,
our AI services
run on the Edge channels,
such as mobile devices and IoT
gateways.
For Edge scenarios,
IoT gateways equipped
with Google TPUs
and Google Coral
are our primary recommendation
to run visual inspection.
The key consideration
to include Edge AI
is to support use cases that
require almost zero latency.
For example, running
visual inspection
and capturing objects on a video
with 3,200 frames per second,
providing data
privacy and supporting
low-bandwidth scenarios.
We provide an Edge AI-enabled
Android and iOS mobile app
services.
And for the IoT gateways, we
offer an enterprise grade Edge
stack that consists of Cloud
connectivity, security,
Cloud-based orchestration,
and software updates
to Google Cloud, an Edge
application run layer,
running visual
inspection business logic
consists of
customized [INAUDIBLE]
apps integrated with
TFLite contest AI models
that are built and managed
through Google Cloud.
Google Cloud serves as
the core Cloud platform,
providing the Edge and
Cloud-based AI models.
Through AutoML, the AI platforms
for especially like custom
models and industry-ready AI
products such as manufacturing
visual inspection.
As our solution
includes Edge IoT,
the Cloud IoT core supports
Edge orchestration and device
management, integration
with [INAUDIBLE]
and https-like interfaces.
The segmented or processed
visual inspection data
generated to Cloud
or Edge AI inference
be it streaming or batch-type
are transformed with the Google
Cloud data and ML services,
supporting various business
applications such as inclusion
quality monitoring dashboard
or custom real-time
workflows running either
on the Cloud or on-prem
with containerized
and [INAUDIBLE] like solution.
We have been successful
in productizing
an innovative concept of
AI-based visual inspection
to a client-ready
production solution
is mainly because of
the technology value
Google is bringing in through
a managed and scalable Cloud
AI and data services.
We have been able to
achieve faster time to value
with minimum efforts due to
technology such as smart data
labeling tools on Google Cloud.
It reduces your labeling
efforts and help
in building efficient
AI training data sets.
AutoML-like products minimizes
your AI development efforts
and provide mature AI models
for object detection, object
tracking, and image
classification.
To support complex
inspection environments,
you can build once and
deploy your AI model,
either on the Cloud or
on the Edge offline,
supporting multiple AI
prediction channels supported
by Google Cloud.
Other managed Google Cloud
and ML data services provide
scalability and
acceleration in fulfilling
real-time applications and
ML optimized reporting of AI
inspected data.
Now each client's
story is different.
However, we have sketched
out a common approach that
is a best practice that
allows us to deliver
fast and efficiently.
First, we identify
the business needs.
This involves understanding the
business case for each asset
and determining which
assets are worth pursuing.
Additionally, we
choose our approach.
When we are looking
for small items that
are hard to distinguish
from backgrounds,
we opt for segmentation.
However, most of our clients
have found great success
in sticking to object detection
services from Google Cloud.
To begin with, defining
the right data set.
As every data set is known,
data is the key here.
We build our sets
such that we have
at least 100 labels per
classification of object
to begin with AutoML.
Accenture's advanced
AI capabilities
bring expertise in building
super efficient data
sets with custom labeling
techniques and data
augmentation, depending on
the complexity of the images
or videos and exclusively
to improve the performance
of the models on [INAUDIBLE].
We leverage AutoML object
detection to detect
and classify assets.
If we find the
accuracy of the model
is lacking for particular
assets or if data
set needs to be augmented
with features or a threshold
needs to be adjusted
per asset, we
turn to custom
model development.
In custom model development,
we use AI platform notebooks
to augment custom models
with pre-trained networks
to achieve better
accuracy all available
as part of Google
Cloud AI platform.
We support complex model
deployment and predictions.
This can then be
published into dashboards
with Cloud predictions,
or deployed
onto Edge, triggered by either
manual events or automated
services.
Now on top of our technical
platform, as mentioned before,
we are offering some of our
exclusive industry solutions
with tailored AI and application
services for enterprises.
In energy, for utilities,
we perform a quality check
of the utility boards.
For upstream energy
production industry,
we provide safety services,
such as real-time inspection
of leakage detection in a
plant and worker safety gear
compliance monitoring in a
hazardous working environment.
To address COVID-19
related challenges
at enterprises that
are returning to work,
we have a visual
tracking solution
that monitors safety distancing
between workers and face mask
monitoring like services.
In production environments
involving industrial workers,
we offer worker productivity
tracking services.
In the retail industry,
such as at the stores,
we offer in-store customer
behavior and shelf stock
monitoring for effective
stock replenishment.
For life sciences,
that is health sector,
AI visual inspection
plays key productive role
in performing quality checks
for the research samples.
A new upcoming visual
inspection solution
in partnership with
Google involves
bringing an end-to-end quality
inspection transformation
for semiconductors,
starting from fabrication
to [INAUDIBLE].
Exclusively for the
manufacturing industry,
we're jointly
working with Google
in bringing AIVI transformation
in performing a quality
check for the product defects,
missing compliance and missing
product components.
Now let me introduce some
of our success stories
we have achieved
with Google Cloud.
For utilities, we developed
a utility pole inspection
solution to automatically
and accurately identify
damaged utility as well as
healthy inventory equipments
on the poles using exclusively
Google's AutoML AI product.
The vision AI process data is
further processed and analyzed
for predictive maintenance
and actionable insights.
The business value
that we deliver here
was to provide
actionable insights
for wildfire
mitigation scenarios
and include asset tracking.
For another utility
provider, we developed
a [INAUDIBLE] mobile Edge
visual inspection app
to perform quality check
of the utility poles
during post installation
and maintenance.
The Edge AI visually
processed utility pole data
brought tremendous value
in improving the inspection
process at the back
office, reducing
false positive and
false negative scenarios
for the inspectors.
At an automotive manufacturing
production facility
that involved monitoring
workers at multiple stations
in a production
line, the challenge
was the assembly line
supervisor had no visibility
to line in balances
of worker bottlenecks.
These bottlenecks and
out-of-balance conditions
persisted for prolonged
periods, impacting
productivity and quality.
To address these challenges,
we built an AutoML-based Edge
object tracking solution,
deployed on Google Coral IoT
gateway to tracking assets
and final assembly worker
movements within an
outside assembly stations,
maintaining the privacy of
worker images on the Edge
and transmitting only the
segmented data to the Cloud,
thereby alerting
supervisors when
bottlenecks or out-of-balance
conditions were detected.
And for our life
sciences clients,
we developed an autonomous
Google visual inspection
solution to analyze
bacteria samples
and assess different quality
types before carrying out
advanced research.
Here, a programmed
robotic arm picks up
Petri dishes with samples that
have to undergo quality check
and places them under a camera
integrated with an H gateway
running AI visual
inspection models,
analyzing these
samples in real time
and then instructing these
robotic arms to place
the different quality
categories of bacterias
into a designated pit.
The value we were
able to provide here
is to effectively utilize lab
technician's time for higher
value tasks and let AI do
the mundane type of quality
inspection checks, thereby
reducing inspection
time by 80% through
automation, as well reducing
the false positive rates by 10%.
For retail, we built an AI and
IoT driven visual inspection
solution on Google Cloud AI
platform and Google Coral
with the camera
tracking inventory
levels of these promotional
shelves items in real time.
Simultaneously, we
also carried out
performing planogram
compliance checks.
And this inspected
data alerted workers
to take actions before they turn
into real business problems.
With this, we were able to
bring inventory automation,
overcoming out of
inventory scenarios
efficiently by utilization and
improved customer experience.
Another valuable experience
we conducted at retail
is measuring customer
behavior in store.
And this is to optimize in-store
customer experience with better
services and operations.
And all of this is done with
a privacy-first mindset,
processing customer
visual data on the Edge.
With this, I end
my presentation.
And over to you, Ying.
YING FEI: Thanks Sudhi.
Next, let's take a look
at the video from Siemens.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIGRAN BAGRAMYAN: Factories
need artificial intelligence
to harness the power
of detailed data
and consistently
provide granular metrics
to increase quality.
Visual inspection AI automates
quality control process
and helps achieve cost savings,
improving work efficiency.
Based on the learning
and experience
gained with internal use cases,
Siemens is building AI products
that we offer to our customers.
So we put together
a technology stack
that runs AI models in real
time right on production lines
so that we can
intelligently inspect
every single unit produced.
ALEXANDER KLEEFELDT: At
Siemens digital industries
motion control
factory in Erlangen,
we're implementing AI
for different use cases
in electronics manufacturing.
We want to automate
inspection processes
like circuit board assembly,
soldering, and packaging.
Let's take a closer look
at one of our examples.
Every day at
packaging stations, we
prepare thousands of produced
units and accessories
for shipping to our customers.
Whether the operation
is manual or automated,
it can happen that
small accessories
are mixed up or missing.
With AI, we can monitor the
packaging process in real time
and immediately
notify the worker
if a package was incomplete.
AI models can
detect small objects
in a video stream, whatever
their position on a conveyor
belt is.
That was not possible
with algorithms
before that required the
exact location of all objects
and couldn't tolerate occlusion
or changes in lighting.
With AI solutions,
we can minimize
the number of
incomplete packages
and corresponding costs.
This increases throughput
and eliminates rework.
TIGRAN BAGRAMYAN: We use
multiple core AI technologies,
among which those
provided by Google.
For example, Cloud-based service
AutoML is very convenient,
and for some operations like
data annotation or model
training, even colleagues from
production engineering or IT
not specifically trained for
data science can perform them.
We see the potential
of AI, and we
are implementing
it in our factories
first to deliver well
thought, innovative,
and tested products
to the market.
We believe artificial
intelligence
is the future of automation
and essentially the future
of manufacturing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
YING FEI: Thanks Siemens team
for sharing the great story.
At Google Cloud, we
appreciate the collaboration
with all partners and
customers for building out
the visual inspection solution
to transform the manufacturing
industry.
SUDHINDRA KRISHNAMURTHY:
Thank you, Ying.
On behalf of Accenture,
I thank Google Cloud team
for the joint collaboration
in bringing innovation
to our clients.
Over to you, Ying.
YING FEI: If you would
like to learn more
about this new solution,
please reach out
to your sales rep
at Google Cloud,
and they will share
more information,
more details about using
the product with you.
Thank you.